[Music]
you heard about the kdm 1v4 with the
p250 i haven't heard of that how does it
go chad well it's a pretty important
round it was for the title he actually
won it with just that pic that p250 i
can't believe nobody was looking and he
managed to sneak his way all the way
through the back lines here and shoot
shiro at the back of the head right and
what did he do after that that's nuts so
so he actually shoots the oprah in the
back of the head without anyone looking
that's the op and kills the guy ct oh
yeah
oh oh my god he's knifed him and he's
gotten away with the orb i'm starting to
get nervous there's no way there's no
way katie you can't win pro league like
this you can't win pro league like this
no way
exo's left 40 seconds and the bombs on a
take your time son you're about to make
the play of your career gets the info he
just has to hit this shot and he's done
it for heroic the leader
calling well above his years clearing
the night
you're an animal heroic you've done it
and i just can't believe it canadian
casper
he does it with nothing
in march 2020 before the online era of
cs go started kadyan was a rising force
in the scene his team heroic pushed into
the top 20 of hltv's global rankings and
a big part of that success was the
danish opera himself
[Music]
but heroic was never able to get much
further than that struggling to go deep
at big lands they weren't doing poorly
but they needed to do better kaden's own
career wasn't all that exciting either
he was a beloved player on middling
teams who never really made much of a
name for himself so he needed a big win
and the inaugural season of flashpoint
set to take place in los angeles seemed
like the perfect place to move up in the
rankings we went to the us
with the knowledge of having a
flashpoint spot for season one
and uh
and being signed by fpx i mean it was
all announced uh standing there and the
jerseys having a real good timer for
cadian who spent years proving himself
and getting to this point it seemed like
things were finally moving in the right
direction but then
everything collapsed we as fpx
heroic
call us whatever name you want will not
be finishing the first group stage of
flashband
probably just won't be playing the
cinnamon roll let's be real
his teammate essetag announced he was
headed to astralis and then fpx decided
to drop everyone funbless phoenix has
actually forfeited their match to orgles
essetag is going to astralis now
uh yeah everything uh everything's not
going great for fun plus phoenix because
of fpx's decision kaden and his
teammates had to forfeit the flashpoint
group stage while they were stuck in a
foreign country in the middle of a
global pandemic i still remember just
setting up to play the second game a
flashpoint
and sitting there warming up with our
gear
and then
we get a call from
our owner of the organization eric and
he's just like yeah
stop playing like there's no knees you
guys are not going to play
as the world realized the severity of
the global pandemic esports had to
change tournaments went on a line a
disappointing switch for cs fans and
many top cs go teams found it difficult
to switch to online play multiple
players temporarily stepped away from
astralis roster na'vi falter despite
strong land results from just before the
pandemic and mousesports looked like a
shadow of their former selves but kadyan
and his teammates saw a new opportunity
they rejoined heroic and took the online
era seriously even hiring hunden as
their coach in april hunden had been a
long time igl in danish counter-strike
and had played alongside glaive before
he became a legend in his own right as
part of astralis he brought a wealth of
knowledge about the game itself and the
opponents that kadian would need to beat
theresa top i think when i came to
heroic in the beginning of like may last
year um
i think i saw at a different gadian the
cadian who just wanted to play a bit
a free play style uh with no structure
let's just run around and then i do a
lot of mid run callings he likes to talk
a lot so that that fits him perfectly
hunden and kadian figured that if the
other top teams were taking it easy then
heroic could close the gap by grinding
and training until they could become the
best team in the world and after
qualifying for esl one cologne 2020 it
was time to show the world just how
dangerous they could be in the online
era now he can be very quick behind them
they're going up hey and kadian if that
smoker rise i think they're going to
disrespect it he's got a good chance at
another here canadian's on for four
maybe even the eighth go on canadian he
takes over the game
ah that's another head off of ammonic
maybe teslas can do it he does it big
time players making big time plays in
big time games tesla's keeps heroic in
it if he could just make destructive
play one two the head of apex gone my
eye is starting to roll and shots is in
trouble
that's enough he's won the round on his
own
nico on for the ace he dismantles
vitality
and
for grand final point for the trophy
this is the first cologne for bob
kadian texas and they're the last team
standing unbelievable
watching heroic and cadian win cologne
was pretty surreal but the dream didn't
last long before it was shattered i've
got this game loaded up it's heroic
versus astralis it's the match we're
hunting for the first 10 rounds
had a coach camera or had a camera and
free cam on banana
days after their huge win hunden was
implicated in a scandal he was one of
several coaches who abused a bug that
allowed him to move around the map
rather than be locked to a player's pov
he was suspended by heroic and banned
for a year i think everyone like got
surprised about what actually happened
i think
most of them got disappointed as well
and in the end of the day we try to find
the best solution i was not the one who
who asked to stay in heroic the
organization the team knew
what i could do with this team so so in
the end of the day i did a big mistake
but they gave me a second chance but the
timing also meant that there were a lot
of questions about heroic's recent
success glaive wanted to know just how
was it that heroics players didn't
realize that their coach was cheating
and so just as kadyan earned the biggest
win of his career it seemed as if the
cheating scandal ripped it all away
[Music]
after the scandal heroic played a ton of
matches trying to prove that they were
still a good team so basically we have
96
apps played in the past three months
yeah we participated in literally
everything that we possibly could and
all of their hard work paid off as
heroic earned the number one spot on
hltv's global rankings finally putting
kaiden ahead of astralis who tailed him
at number two and then at dreamhack open
fall 2020 heroic proved that their
previous success wasn't a fluke five
versus three for heroic to close this
tournament to win yet another online
event to cement themselves at the top of
counter-strike shocks trying his
damnedest apex with only 14 hp 1v3 and
get ready for acadian pop off cause he's
done it he closes and leads his team to
yet another win unfortunately heroic
didn't hold on to that number one spot
for very long they slid as far as 14th
after a disappointing early exit from
iem he's looking around the side sees
his man but no
shiro takes the fight takes the win 16-3
heroic football but heroic were not
about to give up under kadyn's
leadership the team reinvented itself
once again nico and borap were benched
and refreshed and shoes were brought
into his replacements and they
immediately meshed with cadian's system
has to pick up the pieces with a bomb
not planted for him either they don't
know about refresh and he pounces out
with a double and a third refresh denies
the defuse tesses is still here fighting
to the very end and katy and even
rotates him with his tech nine trying to
deny them this ramp control get out says
kadian it's only yuri he's been fragging
up a storm but they're holding the line
and it's all refreshes what an
announcement and during the grand finals
of esl pro league season 13 kadian did
something that no one expected that's
the op and kills the guy ct oh yeah ah
yeah
oh my god he's knifed him and he's
gotten away with the off i'm starting to
get nervous
there's no way there's no way kaden you
can't win pro league like this you can't
win pro league like this
no way
exiles left 40 seconds and the bombs on
a take your time son you're about to
make the play of your career gets the
info he just has to hit this shot and
he's done it for heroic
the leader
calling well above his ears clearing
corners
you're an animal heroic have done it and
i just can't believe it
cadian's 1v4 clutch sealed the win for
heroic and earned the team 150 000
but even more importantly it was a
crowning moment in cadian's career-long
struggle for recognition i think it took
me maybe five ten seconds to realize but
the rush from celebrating and and
and being hyped by my teammates i nearly
passed out you can see in the video i'm
just falling backwards and they're like
catching me kadyan worked his ass off
fighting through losses heartbreak and
scandal because he knew he had what it
took to be one of the best he just
needed that one win that one play that
would immortalize him forever he took a
group of overlooked danish players to
the highest level and gave them a chance
to make history back in the days 2019
both heroic met lions optic whatever
what team all of these players played on
we we were lucky to meet a top 10 team
one time each month now we're used to it
we have the experience now we have the
structure we are ready to to compete
with the best now i'm 100 sure and no
matter what happens when counter
cathedrals again play host to the
faithful the name cadian is now
justifiably revered
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring that notification bell for unique
bite size videos you won't find anywhere
else hit up our instagram twitter and
facebook pages